[Music]
welcome back to our fifth annual
Halloween special today I have my lovely
wife Sam who has joined me for all four
previous years and is now joining me on
some singular reviews for our Halloween
special this year today we're gonna be
talking about child's play
came out in 1988 directed by Tom Holland
not spider-man so I'm curious I actually
don't know this about you when was the
first time you saw a child's play I
think it was like eight or nine years
old you were young yeah we're a child I
was an actual child when I saw this um
and the funny part is I laughed through
most of it I think yeah it is kind of a
funny movie it is it is and it's like I
didn't know it at the time and then I
realized as I got older and watched like
those vintage Halloween horror films
this is definitely paying homage to that
style of like the 60s and 70s thriller
horror films more than like the 80s
slasher films that we started to get
yeah it's it's oddly disconnected from a
lot of the 80s slasher movies that were
inspired by Halloween and 78 and all the
Jason movies after that this one doesn't
really feel like them I mean it has a
killer who kills people with a knife but
the fact that it's a doll and that in a
way the main protagonist is actually a
small boy supposedly when this movie
came out because obviously I was just
being born there were boycotts due to
the level of violence and the fact that
it was a kid and a doll
I don't know I don't really consider it
the more violent of the horror films
I've seen like I've seen way worse
obviously my dad didn't have it probably
watching it when I was like
eight nine years old because it's not
it's not as graphically violent as I
think some of the slasher films are I
kind of don't understand I think it's
because people just weren't used to
seeing a child and a doll that's what it
is situation that's definitely what it
is it's the subject matter combined with
the kid and the fact that it's a doll
and I don't really consider it that
violent either I mean there are some
moments of gore but most of it is hidden
or off screen like when Chucky pushes
the woman out of the window
you basically just see like a
first-person point of view of Chucky
coming towards her and then you get like
a really cool shot of her falling out of
the window but I mean it's it's not all
that violent really and so I don't
really consider this movie to be
anything that parents were concerned
about when I first came out it's quite
fun actually yeah it's a really fun
horror film actually and I I've always
enjoyed it it's not like one of those
ones written like okay I've seen it
enough I'm like I can just keep everyone
watch it every or not have any issues
are you watching it and you always
notice new things like this pastime you
watching it I noticed more alike things
like Stanley Kubrick and Don or
Hitchcock had done like the director Tom
Holland paint kind of an homage to those
style of horror films more less so than
the like that Michael Myers style so it
was like I saw a lot of like The Shining
on this you're absolutely right actually
Tom Holland was really inspired by
Hitchcock he was the writer of psycho 2
which was like actually not too bad
for a psycho sequel and so I think when
he finally got to take the reins of a
horror film he definitely wanted to pay
homage to a lot of his heroes and when I
watched child's play it kind of comes
off I told this the other day it kind of
comes off like a rated hour goosebumps
episode basically it is a reader darkest
episode and I love it for that yeah the
rest of the series is kind of that same
quirkiness I that the fact that I'm they
completely changed point of view in the
next following ones where it's Chucky is
now the main care
versus the child is the main character
definitely twisted it up but so far I
mean they have what's seven movies seven
yeah if you include the new cult of
Chucky right and that's and they're all
still from what I remember it's been a
long time ten sixteen most of them might
have not seen the last two you just
recently seen them yeah so since
everyone will ask my opinion of the
Chucky's I have recently marathon all of
them except Colton Chucky I haven't
watched a cult yet but child's play is
good
child's play too ain't too bad three is
kind of weird like it takes place in a
military school it has a couple really
cool gory moments where Chucky like no
spoilers I guess but there's with a big
fan if you've seen it you know I'm
talking about
then they got straight comedy that was
in the late 90s where after a screen
came out and they became obsessed with
making horror comedies so Bride of
Chucky was a straight comedy and it was
okay it has a couple fun moments if you
don't take it too seriously seed of
Chucky is insanity that movie it starts
with a CGI shot of Chuckies sperm going
through Tiffany and that's that movie
was yeah yeah that's nice let's put it
that way it did the military ones
yelling when I haven't seen and the
newest one so you can skip three three
and the newest one are the only ones out
the series I've not seen since I've seen
one two and then Bride of Chucky seed of
Chucky yeah cursive Chucky actually
isn't too bad that one took the horror
roots back and made it more just about
Chucky killing people and that one's not
too bad the main girl is in a wheelchair
the whole time and I think that was sort
of like their way of saying okay well in
modern day I think audiences know you
can probably just run away from a doll
really quickly so they took that
convenience away from the main character
and gave her a wheelchair that one's not
too bad yeah this is probably still the
best one though yeah I mean as a whole
though the series does hold up fairly
well when you compare it to maybe
something like the Halloween series
strays off series or scream series where
it's like they progressively do this
high and low thing yeah just
it sees on a parallel pretty much the
whole time with a couple little nice
spikes of like hey this one's better
than this one but none of them are bad
it's true most people don't really talk
about the Chucky movies as much anymore
talk about him has resurfaced more with
the recent like cult called the Chucky
and curse of chucky but yeah I mean I
recently marathon 2 all the Saw movies -
and for me after like - they all kind of
just bottomed out 6 is okay that's what
I've heard excited thinking I only made
it through 1 and 2 and then after that I
heard 3 and the rest were all so bad
that it wasn't worth time to see him the
Chucky movies are fairly consistent cuz
like the first one I don't really
consider it like a classic like
Halloween or something or psycho but
it's a fun enough horror movie that knew
what it was that was enjoyable enough
that had surprisingly fantastic
animatronics Brad Dourif voices Chucky
and all of the films still and its
original he played Charles Lee right in
the very beginning and he's amazing he
is so good as Chucky like he is one of
my favorites evil doll voices which I
guess that's sort of like a very small
group of people I really love them I
don't think I could see anybody else
playing that voice at this point Chucky
is the type of villain that wasn't too
present in slasher movies at the time
because most of them were just faceless
mask-wearing silent people who kill
people the idea of this little thing
that could infiltrate your home and be
viewed as completely innocent by
everyone and most of the Chucky movies
follow a similar formula that someone
knows about Chucky and what he can do
and no one believes him or her and this
one started that formula and something
that doesn't really get a lot of
attention in this movie ever from what I
hear is Catherine Hicks her performance
is damn good it really is the child is
really good in this - absolutely I mean
considering you don't see him he's the
protagonist but you don't see him for a
lot of the movie because they obviously
he goes away for a little while and
things like
so he's honestly like he feels like he's
part of the movie without getting that
stupid like little kid detached a
segment seeing real like oh this feels
very force like the child's not really
yeah it's like this shiny where that
actual the child act on the shiny nailed
what he was supposed to be doing to so
it's like that's good directing on
everybody's part the fact that like they
use children who don't have a lot of
experience are able to keep up with
people who have a lot more experience
yeah I seem out of place
absolutely this movie had a lot riding
on it if the actors didn't commit if the
puppetry didn't work out the whole thing
would fail and the actors commit I mean
Catherine Hicks is most known for
seventh heaven the TV show later but she
was in like Star Trek for this film in
the 80s she had a very promising movie
career and went in a TV after that but
she really commits I mean if you really
think about I mean this is someone
holding a doll trying to act as hard as
they can and but she does a great job
yeah I mean it's honestly hard to look
at a blank screen and act towards a
blank screen instead of talking to
somebody like that's directly across
from you I'm like so I applaud the
acting in this and I'm surprised by some
of like the special effects they use
like the explosions and the lightning
and a lot of thought went into making
sure that everything mattered in what
they were doing and like all of the
scenes have a point to them and there's
not like a whole bunch of extra dead end
plot holes that you're like well lots of
this everything loops back and finishes
off and closed circles instead of you
being left like going oh okay
like I said this isn't a perfect movie I
mean it's a very guilty pleasure fun
Halloween film it's it's not a classic
as a film that started a huge franchise
it's not great but I guess my only real
issues with it are the whole voodoo
subplot is very hand fist it in there
just to be like how do you explain the
doll thing and his abilities well he had
a voodoo teacher once let's go find him
yeah and in Anthony says how you kill
him and it's just so quick and throw
them together really quick and a lot of
horror movies do this when I review
Jason lives and I rewatched it Tommy
Jarvis finds these these occult books in
his car and reads a really quick and
goes okay
I gotta kill Jason and can't Crystal
Lake I know how to do it and then that's
it and that was sort of the trend back
then was there's this unstoppable force
how do you kill him they find out in two
seconds and then we're back running
along again yeah that's not the only
complaint I would have how did this
woman come into her home onto a crime
scene or somebody just got murdered and
throw the police out of her house yeah
that's true all I know is that I've just
lost my best friend tonight to a
horrible accident and I would like some
time along with my son who I'm sure it's
just as upset about this as I am
sorry I'm sorry I'll clear everybody out
of here right away okay I don't want you
to be here okay all right guys clear out
you don't get to tell police they don't
have to leave my house it's just a
murder scene it's like no that's just
not how hard all right I don't want you
guys to be here guys I have to clean up
the evidence right they wouldn't allow
that so there there are some story flaws
but not like things that don't get
explained yeah and what a movie is this
like tongue and cheek and an aware of
its silliness and just plain enjoyable
to watch sometimes sometimes flaws just
kind of vaporize you know and you're
just like fucking cares I mean there are
a few movies that I can watch where I'm
like I really don't care that much about
this right now like I just enjoy
watching it and child's play is one of
those because most of the time I'm super
analytical and I'm you know looking at
movies like that's how I talk to and I
watch them yeah yeah that's true he does
talk like it's not a voice that's not
uncommon
so yeah if you've never seen the first
child to play or any of the Chucky
movies that recommend starting with this
one you don't necessarily have to watch
all the sequels but they're fun I mean
you know they're there isn't to me
anyway a truly awful one because the
ones that I would say are probably the
worst are like the self-aware comedy
ones and it's hard to say they're
terrible when they're trying so hard to
be so self-aware but the first one is
definitely the best it has surprisingly
good performances and amazing
animatronics I'm gonna get child's play
a B+ and I am going to get child's play
a B a B for being my big bad boy ya know
um it's as you said it's it's been all
around it's a good watch is it a perfect
film no it's a bad film no but it's a
fun film to watch and especially for
Halloween yeah I mean it fits into the
Halloween stuff like I mean what more
can you ask from a movie about a doll
yeah especially since nowadays like
everyone's like Oh Annabelle oh my gosh
you know the conjuring up like there
were evil doll movies before people like
this this is the og give some respect to
the og evil doll thank you my beautiful
wife for joining me on this review of
child's play we're gonna have some more
leading up to Halloween with you yes I'm
going to friendly be in some of them I'm
excited to have you the videos are much
better with her considerably better
better more appealing that's for sure
than having a look at this face the
whole time yeah thank you very much guys
for watching look forward to more in the
Halloween special and as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck and wonder I hope I give a
dent you would put in a car if I showed
you a window hmm okay
[Music]